[Music]
you
are going to witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
are you ready
because this film i feel like from the
title everyone has been like well what
is it because it's definitely no we got
that but we don't know what else it is
so when did the name come to you it came
after i wrote the script and we were in
i think we were in pre-production or we
might have even been in production and
realizing that this film had become
something
uh even bigger and different than what i
had set out to do
and
you know there's lots of names that i
was circulating in my head and at the
end of the day the film felt singular
and nope was the only thing that i could
i could say to describe it gosh that's
so true having seen the film and i want
to encourage folks after you see it to
come back to this interview because
it'll all make sense then i promise real
quick was there another alternate name
you're going to throw for us you want
another scoop yeah please so when i was
writing the script it was called little
green men
okay and i get that you know i'm always
talking about something um human a human
flaw
and there was something about
our connection with spectacle and money
and our monetization of spectacle yeah
and so the little green men that i
started talking about was was the little
green man on the money
yeah there's so much yeah but you see
how that sort of sounds like
it sounds like some kind of like
red box
like
9 2003
like
jeff fahey vehicle
you know what i'm talking about yes
it's not i don't want to be the little
green man i'm like no it's not it's easy
and um
anyway so nope i love that okay well i
will say this there's a thing about
spectacle in this which is insidious
just literally insidious and i don't
think it's something that people can
really grasp until they see the film
but knowing that it's also going to be a
universal ride which by its definition
is spectacle
how does that sort of like you are
hyping up spectacle even in this film
but also causing it as a cautionary tale
is that where this just lives in that
you know what yeah a part of it was i'm
i'm gonna make something that people
have to see and then while i was making
it i'm trying to
figure out what's wrong with that why do
we have to see anything why is it that
we why do we rubberneck at an accident
why do we have to open our um social
media and see the worst thing in the
world every morning before we go to that
is something in human nature and so i
felt like yes i want people to come out
see my movie i want to give them
an escape but i can't ignore the fact
that there's something intrinsically um
insidious about that yeah okay so
it's got a ride that says let's get the
oprah shot let's get the franchise is
that what you're saying with this one or
do you really feel it's singular
oh well i
um no comment
ah you already got yours no i got my
school but i will take that i'm talking
rich and famous for life there's plenty
of videos for flying online ain't nobody
gonna get what we gonna get what are we
gonna get the money shot what's up
undeniable proof of aliens on camera
the oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no kiki daniel i do have to say uh
the film is incredible because it really
talks about a bad miracle which is
basically this idea of when the dream
turns into a nightmare and so of course
the next
question is what would be the dream that
you're saying right now oh i want it but
you know if you've got it it'd be
terrible kiki i'll start with you
like what's your bad miracle so i think
as entertainer the dream is to be
successful i don't think you really
think about the fame aspect of that you
just think about like i want to be able
to work as an actor you know and be able
to make a living off of art which can be
so difficult um so i think that was the
dream and then the nightmare was fame
the night where was it was that it for
you too like i'll just see dances over
here just like
fame oh you really want to have a
conversation about i mean let's do it
yeah no no like
i say similar like like having a leader
in the film was the dream like i was
like i just want to lead the film i just
want to do i just want to do it let's
get out
what's happening
where does everyone watch this what's
happening i'm trying to go to the phone
shop
yeah i think you told me one time about
you went out in public at a moment when
you knew that you shouldn't and you were
like i shouldn't have been out here
it got crazy when i went to london it
was just like i just walked in the
street and then went yeah
and i was like oh
things have changed things have changed
so i think we know what the bad miracle
is does that mean that you would feel
the same way about alien life like you
would not even want to go anywhere near
it like if somebody was saying to us
right now in the desert out in joshua
tree someone texts you they think they
see aliens are you gonna go
are you not even gonna go
someone if someone takes me someone says
are you gonna go joshua tree is a little
bit out in the middle of nowhere so
there's literally nowhere for us to all
right so absolutely not okay someone
texts me come to joshua tree i would go
that's a trap
aliens are not
someone say hey there's aliens here yeah
you're i'm deleting your number i'm
blocking you
especially in an area like josh retreat
we're not even in a city we ain't got a
winner i really do appreciate the black
folks preservation where we all i think
for the most part like unless it was at
your house like it isn't this you ain't
going and even then we try to leave um
daniel i do i'm not gonna ask you
because you're under contract but kiki
maybe you'll be willing to like have you
tried to like get any black panther
spoilers out of this one on set because
if that's where i was i would at least
try to ask did y'all start filming black
panther no but i would ask are y'all
doing a zoo am i gonna dance i did i did
all right like i'm not in it
i'm not in it so it is they are doing
this they all do i didn't they are doing
one so then i was doing it i was filming
this i was filming filming this so it
clashed
it clashed i wasn't
okay if this ends up being an andrew
garfield moment where you're in it and
you lied to me i will find i'll be funny
though
i should do that they ain't gonna be
live that's right i thought you gotta
try nah you know all right we'll see
only on screen when you act all right
kiki one more real quick because i have
to ask about dear kiki is one of my
favorite things in the face of the year
do you give does she give that advice
real life on set no
no she does yes i do yeah
he doesn't listen to it though what's
the best advice you've got real quick i
guess it's trying to switch off when she
gets here but i like i know you know
what is you know i'm that guy like i've
been listening someone like annoys me
i'm like
you're right
and i won't do it for about a week and
then i'll do it to feel like it's my
idea
so she probably does but i feel it's my
idea
i can't remember what it is so
you know i try to take a little
summertime you know what i mean i got my
boy you know i'm like no got your back
you know
i mean i really do love both of you in
this and just being here you've
brightened my
seriously my wednesday i'm like emmy
like tired and like but i'm like you two
just brightened up my day so thank you
very much but i have to ask was it like
that as far as you guys being on set
because y'all were not remote but santa
clarita ain't like in it so like did
going out there really sort of bring you
guys into this moment to just feel like
you could look towards the sky and be
happy like that and like believe that
there was aliens coming out there was
that a part of what made it so real
i think the location is incredible and
so then when i was like sometimes i
don't know how you feel like when i was
on set then we was like down time i
would just look at the mountains yeah
and it does it is like a what is when
the location running place you just
would stare and just look at the view
and take in so i'd understand why you'd
want to look up and gaze yeah i agree i
think yeah the location is just as much
a part of the outfit as the clothes and
you know that it all informs the
character so being out there made us
feel like oh we in an isolated area
what's going on you know
i need you to tell me what did you see
in that cloud
well it's not what you think
they took me
they took them all
stephen first of all let me go ahead and
say congratulations on the film it's
incredible because i feel your character
and pt barnum could have a lot to talk
about yeah you know what i'm saying he's
like he's very much a showman and it is
it is very much about like that that
aspect of spectacle so i have to ask you
what do you think about that like what
aspects of that showmanship as like you
know he's a formal charles star is that
something that
you anybody who plays dress up and wants
to be an actor yeah spectacle and
showmanship is like a huge part of that
so was that fun to really sort of dive
into yeah it was really fun also scary
um
also isolating
um
spectacle is an interesting idea
especially if you are the spectacle
itself um
maybe it feels like you're connecting
but
perhaps you're just being consumed
um i don't know there's so many things
we could talk about but yeah there's
um
we all want it for some reason
right um maybe we all want to we all
watch a car crash unfortunately we all
watch something on fire
and in some way
are we connecting through that shared
experience
but then
what happens to the spectacle itself
like
yeah
you're touching on so much i feel like
for anyone watching this interview if
they're anyway confused come back to it
after it's over because you're gonna
have even more to sort of see within
this that are layers and there's
something about
taming the unknown and taming what's
wild and taming what should maybe not be
tamed in this movie and there's a
through line with your character seeing
that i'm just curious knowing that he
was a child star you know saw
domesticated animals that he worked with
also now in his new life as running this
theme park does it do you think that how
do you think he feels about that like if
he was to examine yeah taming the um the
unruly
i think i think he's i think jupe is um
operating from a place
that might not
be as autonomous as he thinks he is
being
um
you know
it at least for me i feel like it's
easier sometimes to be confirmed of your
traumas
and the ways in which you expect the
world to hurt you or not than it is for
you to see it brand new and give it the
space to just like surprise you um
and jupe
he's pretty tightly in control or wants
to be in control of his destiny and of
his life and
that manifests in ways that maybe he's
learned or seen or been put upon him
yeah i think i think you know
especially trying to tame the wild like
he witnessed gordy
and i wonder if they've connected on
that feeling of
exploitation in a way uh together um as
a child
um
are you fully autonomous of what you're
doing are you aware um it is it is all
it's all there yeah there's a lot going
on and it's so funny so nope is going to
be an attraction at universal and
in the film your character runs an
amusement park and and sort of is the
band leader in that and so it kind of
begs the question about spectacle and
this is a weird place to ask this but
what is your favorite like large-scale
spectacle moment like for me i obviously
the oscars because that to me is my
ultimate spectacle that's my super bowl
and i imagine for you as well but is
there something else that you sort of
see in that grand scale
um
and obsess about it the way that we do
um
i
i don't know if i
have that at the moment but
what's fun is watching my kids run
through that like as they're seeing it
brand new for me i was a huge wrestling
kid as a kid
loved wrestling and the spectacle of
that has had many iterations over my
life when they revealed to me that it
was not real that was a come down
um you know what i mean like yeah
i i mean who broke that that that bubble
for you we have to get out of here this
is why i will say this because i would
love to listen to you talk about
wrestling but
you know this is the director bong
mickey seven can you give me anything if
you know um
cause i know if people haven't seen
ocean please go see it yeah please see
anything there's nothing i can really
tell you because we haven't even really
started
um
instructor bong just trust that process
that's it that's the way to do it i
would do it too that cloud hey moved an
edge it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up
i'll be rooting for you
brandon first of all great to speak to
you again it's been like it seems like
just yesterday we did that first
interview and now that i've seen the
film i have so so many more questions
we're back we are back we're here let's
go well i have a mom's pick with you sir
because you have a lot to do in this
film you like trying to slow play me a
little bit we were getting ready to do
the press and i'm like you've got a lot
going on but it kind of begs the
question as far as like aliens and
conspiracy theories because your
character seems to like run towards that
yeah is that what you would do or like
what is your thought on the like are you
like going down the rabbit hole or you
just like i don't want to know jaclyn
here's the thing
here's the thing
hell no i'm not gonna run towards that
what no i'm an actor man that's not me
i'm not gonna do that angel's crazy
enough he's obsessed enough with aliens
to do that me am i intrigued in aliens
yes am i willing to put myself in the
line like he is
no i'm not i'm gonna do that
that sentiment remains with the entire
cast that i asked i think it's like a
brown person's preservation like i
really do feel this is true like i don't
know if it was a different cast makeup
but they would be turning away from
danger if you know what it is
i'm not going to figure out what it is i
don't care enough i'm too scared no
investigating is how you end up dead
exactly horror movies have taught us
you did also talk about how incredible
it is just looking at this cast i mean
you have oscar nominee oscar winning uh
filmmakers and actors alongside you and
i know it's like dream rolled a book but
also intimidating but what was the like
pinch me moment for you like on set
where you were looking around and you're
just like seeing like this is happening
there's a million pinch me moments but
right now is one of them like you're
here we're talking to rotten tomatoes
like this is crazy no like truly truly
like i'm truly like fanning out right
now and just being on the universal lot
with all this stuff here like for a
movie that i'm in like one of the leads
in i'm pinching myself right now but the
most pinch-worthy moment um
it's hard to detail um i think all of
the group scenes with all of us with
like daniel michael wincott kiki palmer
steven yun and jordan's directing and
hoyt of entertainment's behind the lens
like that's
so many pinch me moments so i think yeah
there's a good there's a really good
scene that we're all just
together and that that that warms my
heart and it's definitely looking around
like
what the heck am i doing like what am i
doing here i'm one of these like this is
insane um
i have to ask like what was your like
ufo movies like were you like a big ufo
alien person before this and did you
come into that with it or any like alien
i would say like affinity or was this
like all new territory um
i mean i've watched all those films
growing up like i've watched alien i've
watched a predator i watched alien verse
predator and then watching like close
encounters of the third kind there's
there's so many different examples uh
signs there's so many different examples
of alien movies i think this does it in
a whole different manner for sure um so
yeah it's it's just different you know
but uh i there was always the intrigue
there and there's always been
fear of it what wigs me out is that why
is everyone green right like there
hasn't like someone's had to see
something like that because why is all
are why are all these artists drawing
the same like little alien and some of
them make them gray or green yeah yeah
like big eyes and like a little teardrop
shaped head
why
what are they hiding jaclyn i don't know
but i would rather you find out than me
because i'm already scared myself
you